jol herzlich willkommen zu diesem video
und zwar habe ich euch mal wieder
aufgefordert mir auf insgesamt fragen zu
stellen und zwar zum thema kino und
effekte und dabei kam das stellt man
eine szene nach und dass sie angeblich
und ich dachte mir ich komme mir beides
und zwar wie folgt ich habe mich warum
ich mir sowas zu machen dass ein objekt
in meinen händen getrackt wird und da
nehme ich den thors hammer und so wie
hier diese maschinenpistole auf diese
strecken orientiert aufgeschreckt wurde
brauchen jetzt noch ein objekt auf das
ich dann den hammer bringen kann und
dafür brauchen wir diesen platz und
anstecknadeln
das ist ja unser hammerkopf steht und
jetzt haben wir unseren absolut geil
haben wir hier am start da kommen jetzt
noch die tracking punkte drauf 2000
jahre später wartet dafür müssen wir
noch bearbeiten und dafür sind jetzt
erstmal ins eis das ist ein tracking
program in diesem programm kann ich
jetzt diese einzelnen punkte hier bild
für bild nachfolgen
also ich habe jetzt mal ein paar punkte
getrackt noch ein bisschen visual
effects magie haben jetzt hier auf der
rechten seite die bewegung des hammers
in 3d und das können wir jetzt auf unser
3d modell übertragen
das sieht dann so aus sie haben wir
jetzt dieses drahtgitter um unseren
hammer herum der perfekt auf dem hammer
drauf setzt ich bin das ziemlich egal ob
sein und jetzt aktive ich mal die
texturen damals unseren hammer
allerdings sieht das noch ein bisschen
ungeil aus weil diese ganzen licht und
schatteneffekte kommen erst wenn wir das
ganze in wenn dann so
das ganze dänischen staat aussehen hier
sind erwartet
das ist das was sie tun
wir sind erwartet
das ist das was sie tun die nächste
frage laute könntest du ri virtuell
hübsch zeichnen also das ist auf jeden
fall richtig richtig schwer aber ich
habe schon eine gute idee und damit
leben hübsches braucht auf jeden fall
erstmal die haare von arizona hier sogar
in der st
dann braucht auf jeden fall noch den
bart von nix oder auszüge und richtiger
kerl ja geil so das ist ein richtig
fantastisch aus soll ich bin seine
gesichtszüge die sind noch nicht perfekt
habe ich ein ganz gutes vorbild so auf
jeden fall müssen seine augenbrauen hier
ordentlich hoch dann würdest du aus wie
thaddeus ja das muss richtig
leidenschaft rein hier bisschen mehr
feuer perfekt aller kann mir jetzt
keiner sagen dass das nicht viel
hübscher als davor und dann kam dann
auch ultra viele fragen zu meinem kurs
und weiteren kursen und vielleicht hat
er schon mitbekommen ich habe einen
schnittkurs endlich veröffentlicht hey
ich bin thomas ich bin auf youtube und
instagram als connery aktiv und arbeitet
als selbständiger visual effects artist
katar und kameramann ich war wieder auf
einer filmschule noch habe ich eine
ausbildung gemacht denn ich habe mir
alles über neun jahre hinweg selbst
beigebracht und deswegen bin ich mir
sicher dass du das auch schafft nur viel
schneller und damit es dir nicht so geht
in mir und du dich jahrelang durch
mittelmäßige tutorials durch - von denen
dann auch noch die allerwenigsten auf
deutsch sind habe ich beschlossen selbst
kurse zu machen mit denen du
schnellstmöglich die welt der digitalen
kunst meisten kannst der kurs ist wie
hier sehr sehr gut strukturiert und
beinhaltet sachen wie filmmaterial
importieren navigation im schnitt
fenster wir gehen ja ganz schmal durch
krebs kopieren das magnet werkzeug
schnitt werkzeug keyframes arbeiten mit
bildern und text wie man verschiedene
effekte anwenden zum beispiel
zuschneiden weichzeichnen wie man falls
sie das firma tri stabilisiert ihr
werdet lernen wie man nun alpha masken
anwendet und wie man mit einem
greenscreen arbeitet und hier unten zum
schluss eben die verarbeitung die
letzten änderungen und natürlich dann
zum schluss wie man das für material
rendert ich habe wirklich und was
bezahlen diesen kurs gesteckt dass man
kann ich mit ganzem herzen sagen dass
ich da wirklich mein wissen in möglichst
kurzer zeitspanne gesteckt hat damit du
möglichst schnell möglichst viel lernen
kannst also wenn ihr bock hatte scheiden
zu lernen schreckt mal in meiner video
beschreibung in erster linie aus da
könnt ihr jetzt in meinem kurs und und
die ersten 50 draufklicken können mit
dem core tm i5 den kurs nur für die
hälfte bekommen also könnt euch und
beeilt euch aber alle anderen ihr könnt
mit dem kot thoma reese 25 prozent
sparen
und wenn ihr euch jetzt aber mehr für
photoshop und nicht vorschnell
interessiert dann war das abkommen auch
noch kurse auf euch zu die man sich dann
kann in naher zukunft so und herzlich
frage die wirklich komplett alles
auseinander genommen hat also die hat
wirklich jeder gefühlt gestellt habe ich
mir schon avengers endgame angeguckt und
was haltet ihr davon
und ja derzeit eine kleine geschichte
und zwar am montag waren wie sophie was
ist dieser unter sebastian was der da
zum avengers endgame ducken und
anschließender in fotoshootings
herrschen verabredet und schon auf dem
weg zum kino habe ich in meinen neuen
schon der alte geblasen dass ich
rumgehüpft bin wie so komplett
sturzbesoffen nachdem ich mir dann bei
der apotheke blasenpflaster geholt habe
ganz klar ohne blasenpflaster kirchen
kein film rein sind wir dann auch mir
nichts dir nichts ins kino gesteppt und
haben uns was zu trinken geholt und was
zu essen geholt der film dauert drei
stunden
dann sind wir in den kinosaal gegangen
haben unsere sitzplätze gesucht und erst
nach zehn minuten erinnert mich der
sebastian werden dass ich doch in den
krasses gehalt dass ein film in dem man
auf gar keinen fall irgendwas liegen
darf und schon gar nix irgendwie
mitschneiden und fehlen darf und dann
ins internet veröffentlichen darf meine
3000 euro 4 kamera mitgenommen hat war
ein bisschen unangenehm tatsächlich
erkennt ja diese illegalen streams
sodass so von kino.to früher die sind ja
immer wir so richtig schlechten kameras
gefilmt ich komme da an war ein mit so
einem richtig großen teil aber auf jeden
fall ein richtig angenehmer als erlebnis
dann mit der kamera in der hand den kino
personal die popcorn tüte und den
lehrern trinkbecher zu geben und dann
herauszugehen und gut also den film fand
ich übrigens gut vor allem defekte war
mal wieder richtig kraft also wenn euch
superhelden filme gefallen dann könnt
euch nächste frage wie lässt man diese
schwarze sonnenbrille einfliegen okay
der will also wissen wie man diese die
widget brille hier ein stück das ist
ganz einfach und zwar muss man da
einfach nur meinen kurs kaufen
spaß und gibt sich einmal links oben bei
position und nach anfänglich nicht
direkt und ich hab mich nach oben und
alle sagen hatte ich gerechnet und jetzt
redet von rein aber kauf durch den kurs
trotzdem
und dann natürlich die offensichtliche
frage was ist mein lieblingsfilm das
habe ich lange zeit mit fed cup und
matrix beantwortet bis ich dann den film
good will hunting gesehen habt ihr mal
so richtig geisteskrank ist ganz ohne
effekte und science fiction überzeugt
dass wir durch eine richtig geile
handlung kann ich euch nur empfehlen
good will hunting richtig geiler film
da ist auch der gute alte robin williams
dabei aber auch matrix unfall treffe ich
immer noch und katalin war richtig nass
aber auch die x-men -reihe findig ultra
geil avatar der film war ein richtig
geiler film also nicht also ne blauen
menschen nicht mehr mit dem fall der
film war kacke die serie geil aber dafür
nicht aber ja prinzipiell alisa battle
entschied der war richtig geil und
generell eigentlich die meisten
animationsfilm mehr und auch die meisten
fällen nicht richtig geilen visual
effects die mag ich die letzte frage
gut das ist keine frage aber
ja also fest dass kommissar überhaupt
wenn es euch gefallen hat dann würde
mich freuen wenn ihren daumen nach oben
lassen will
und wenn der woche hat sie nicht auf
diese reise zu begleiten dann schenkt
mir gerne ab
dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
wieder und nicht vergessen linken der
beschreibung seiner kunst
wenn wir lernen wollt wie man schneidet
[Musik]